[Musique]
spectacle alors
prends donc certains d'entre
eux
notre chef, nous sommes les gens qui
les élisent là-bas donc nous n'en avons pas mais ils doivent
aussi regarder notre propre vol, ils ne peuvent pas
vous annuler juste comme ça là-bas  Y a-t-il des
gens qui l'utilisent comme moyen de Lego,
alors que feraient-ils, qu'en est-il
des gens de production, que
feraient-ils [Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
oui, c'est une bonne nouvelle d'une certaine manière, surtout
pour nous, experts en environnement.  et les
passionnés de durabilité, mais je suppose que
ce sera une mauvaise nouvelle pour la
population dans son ensemble, non seulement de Lagos, mais aussi du
pays dont dépendent réellement leurs moyens de subsistance, qui se
termine dans la chaîne de valeur des déchets plastiques
qui est essentiellement à usage unique.
un Nigeria sans plastique
et nous avons survécu, c'est tout à fait possible
mais je comprends que la
commodité du plastique est assez aveuglante
mais je voudrais dire que cette
commodité au prix de nos vies et de notre
avenir est trop
chère